from Mary Wollstonecraft as we're going
to see the development of the human
person really is conceptualized in terms
of our higher faculties so what a lot of
people would call our intellectual on
the one hand and our moral faculties on
the other hand the two main terms that
she's going to use over and over again
are going to be reason although you'll
also see here talking about intellect or
understanding and also about knowledge
and virtue virtue is probably the term
that you're going to see come up more
than any of these other things in part
because it's really at the center of it
and virtue also involves a kind of
knowledge as well as what we'll see as
we get to this so there are some key
questions that are motivating the
vindication questions that she wants to
respond to in the affirmative and wants
to say that those who have responded to
them and the negative have actually been
been wrong and show why they're wrong so
our women capable of developing virtue
virtue to the same extent virtue of the
same kinds that men are or you know
here's another possibility are their
male virtues and a female virtues maybe
men are supposed to be courageous and
you know go to war and and you know hunt
and be the fire fighters and women are
supposed to have the domestic virtues
like be be nice and kind and gentle and
nurturing that's something she's trying
to tackle right there she's going to
actually say women can develop the same
virtues that men can if they haven't
it's because society has been screwed up
and keeping them from doing that there's
a sort of self-perpetuating cycle that's
been going on but women are capable of
developing every single virtue that a
man is and men should be developing
virtues to the you know there's there's
a tendency to think that by focusing on
women and saying women are capable of
this that somehow that gets anybody off
the hook women are capable and ought to
be developing virtue
men are capable and ought to be
developing virtues insofar as they're
not there's something damaged about the
human condition in them
same thing with reason are they fully
are they capable of fully employing
reason or is there a sort of
irrationality that's built into the
fabric of womankind of femininity again
Wollstonecraft wants to say no that's
not the case and you know she could
point to herself as an example she
doesn't notice that she doesn't make an
example of herself in this sort of stuff
and say look I can do it so therefore
all women can do it she's making an
argument to say that every woman and
every man could be fully rational if
they're not it might be in some respects
their own fault but in many respects
it's going to be the fault of the the
society the institution's the kind of
profession that they're stuck in and the
kind of education or miss education that
it inflicts on them but these were there
are the questions that she's going to be
answering yes to she's got this great
passage at the beginning that I really
want to stress here because it gives you
a great idea about what she's trying to
get at in talking about virtue and
reason so she begins the the chapter
writes an involved duty as a man can
consider the very first chapter of this
work by saying we need to go back to
first principles we need to really think
what should be going on so we got to go
back to human nature we got to see
what's most fundamental so she has been
what does Man's preeminence over the
brute creation consist what makes us
better than the animals than stones than
iPhones you know they are really part of
the brute creation that's not a her time
but you know they're not they're not you
know thinking objects they may be
computers the answers is clear that it's
reason so our capacity to reason for
Wollstonecraft justice for many other
philosophers is essential to what it
means to be a human being for what
acquirement or she says what acquirement
exalts one being above another what
distinguishes us what makes us actually
unequal in a way
a legitimate inequality virtue virtue
moral excellence the bringing to
fruition of our human capacities then
she asks for what purpose were the
passions implanted and we'll come back
to this term passions in just a moment
that man by struggling with them might
attain a degree of knowledge denied to
the Brutes
whispers experience what is it was she
talking about there well you know what
is a passion fear we're afraid of
something do we just run away and you
know never think about it again or do we
do we address our fears do we develop
technology perhaps to figure out what's
going on or if we're afraid of you know
meteorological phenomena you know and we
think that maybe it's not the Angels
bowling as we were kids but the gods
actually you know wanting to rain
boulders down on us or something like
that we develop some some knowledge and
then we are much better off we're not
afraid of that sort of thing we can say
the same thing about all of our other
passions and this is part of how we
develop as human beings in our lives by
feeling something and then trying to
come to terms with it we use our minds
and we're going to come back to this
passions thing in just a second like I
said I want to continue with this she
says the perfection of our nature and
the capability of happiness these are
two really important things happiness
what will actually make us happy what
will truly satisfy us as human beings
what counts as being fulfilled
she says that that's too connected with
the perfection of our nature when she
says perfection of course she's meaning
this in the old sense not as in like
having a checklist where you get
everything right or get a hundred on the
test that's one kind of perfection but
that's a trivial kind of perfection
perfection in the sense of developing
its capacities all the way so you know
we can say that an acorn that sprouts
and grows into an oak tree even if that
oak tree might have some you know bad
spots on it or it's been attacked by
ants so long as it's actually grown into
what it was supposed to grow into it has
reached its perfection
if our nature is to love then if we
don't love we have not reached our
perfection no matter how many great test
scores we get no matter how many
achievements we pile up if on the other
hand you know our whole nature is to do
well on tests then I guess that would be
the perfection of our nature but
Wollstonecraft doesn't doesn't think so
she thinks that the perfection of our
nature the fulfillment of what it is to
be a human being the realization of
human potential Casa de with virtue
reason and knowledge and she gives us a
kind of three-part formula to this
she says the perfection of our nature
and capability of happiness must be
estimated by the degree of Reason virtue
and knowledge that distinguished the
individual so that exists in an
individual how much reason have you
cultivated have you really made
everything of your mind that you can or
have you been lazy in that respect
that depends you know very much on your
education and your own efforts but that
determines whether you're going to be
happy or whether you're going to be
fulfilled
how much virtue have you developed do
you need to develop more do you have
vices that you need to start focusing on
and dealing with do you have a bad
temper
that might be a virtue or an area of
virtue where you need to work on things
you know with respect to - how much
knowledge have you acquired and not just
knowledge in the sense of a lot of
encyclopedia book learning information
how much practical knowledge have you
acquired and how much of what you take
to be knowledge is really knowledge as
opposed to fine spun nonsense that has
just worked for a while how much of your
knowledge is based on understanding of
first principles understanding of causes
and effects systematically understanding
how things actually work as opposed to
happening happening to get it right well
Plato I actually call the difference
between knowledge and right opinion so
long ago we can talk about that as
existing in an individual and in so far
resident exists in that individual
that's going to have an influence on how
happy that person is we can also talk
about it as directing society we can
look at institutions we can look at
families we can look at teams we can
look at anything where human beings are
associated together and there's some
sort of norms and we can say how much
virtue how much reason how much
knowledge is actually at work is
actually embodied in those those
structures in those groups it's just a
little bit you're probably not going to
have a lot of happy people you're
probably going to be making people
miserable making them worse as human
beings they're not going to fulfill
their human potential
so exploitative relationships for
example abusive relationships are
probably going to keep us from having
any sort of happiness not only for the
exploited or abused person but even for
the exploiter or abuser in exercise she
says from the exercise of reasoned
knowledge and virtue naturally flow how
much of this is actually being put into
effect that's the interesting thing
about these if you have virtue it's not
like you just have a quality that sits
there inside of you you know let's take
it one example generosity so you say I'm
a generous person and you just sit by
yourself in your room and you never
interact with anybody else
no you're not a generous person you're
only a truly generous person if you
actually do generous things in relation
to other people in the real world
same thing with reason she's not talking
about a kind of ivory tower
you know armchair analysis or things
she's talking about engaged reason that
allows you to think out your
relationships to think out how you
should structure your day whether you
have good work-life balance all these
sorts of things that are you taking care
of your health that's all manner of
rationality same thing with knowledge
knowledge is not just theoretical
knowledge is also practical so insofar
as these things exist in these settings
human beings will be led to what they're
supposed to be insofar as that's not
going on
human beings are stunted human beings
are kept from realizing their true
potential and they are deprived of
happiness as a result they may be able
to experience certain pleasures they may
be able to you know satisfy certain
desires but that's not the same thing as
full-on happiness in a complete sense so
let's go back to talk about passions so
we mentioned that passions are things
that we we feel and we can think of them
as emotions or drives responses that we
have affective responses and it's
through struggling with them struggling
with these things that we have because
of our human nature which is also animal
nature then we are able to grow so you
know we become courageous we acquire the
virtue of courage by struggling against
our fear it's not that we become
courageous by taking a pill that gets
rid of all of our fear that person is
not courageous or by destroying the you
know fear center in the brain that can
happen with certain diseases pretty
dangerous luckily that's the case you
don't stay away from things that could
kill you we become courageous by
struggling with our passion of fear we
also if we're at the other extreme
become you know courageous as opposed to
rash by struggling with our feelings of
confidence some people are a little bit
too cocky because of that we become
temperate by struggling with their
desires for pleasures for food for drink
for sex for affection for laying in the
Sun we become just by struggling against
our natural human passion that steers us
towards greed and saying no to it saying
you're not going to run the show I'm
going to I'm gonna run the show and I'm
going to try to do the just thing if we
do that long enough we will in fact
become just and we will learn things in
the process we will acquire knowledge
and develop our rationality so you know
she she goes on and she says that we
have to struggle with our
passions by doing so we begin to elevate
ourselves one of the interesting
passions that she's going to talk about
and I'm going to talk more about this in
another video is the passion of love the
passion of attraction of infatuation of
sexual desire that seeks some sort of
connection not just a sexual connection
but something else with the other person
what we do with that
has a huge effect on the kind of human
beings that we become and whether we're
going to be happy or whether we're not
going to be happy so let's go on yeah
sure so the passions should unfold our
our reason which is a nice way to talk
about it
so let's now look at what she has to say
about virtue I'm not going to talk so
much about rationality because we're
going to talk about that a little bit
more in the section and the video on
education but I want to talk about
virtue itself so when we talk about
virtue first off we can say virtue in
the singular and then we mean all the
virtues or we mean a virtue or we can
talk about virtues in the plural and
then we're talking about character
traits like generosity like even temper
like honesty like perseverance these
sorts of things yeah here's a few key
points about virtue that Wollstonecraft
is making in this one is virtues can't
really be developed in a state of
dependency you can develop what she's
calling at certain points the minor
virtue is what you actually turn out to
just be a matter of manners rather than
a morality you know being nice to people
you can become a nice person in a state
of dependency you can't become a good
person a fundamentally good person in a
state of dependency why not well there's
two reasons that she talks about and
some of the passages that she says are
pretty
- literally good here we go
she says women are now allowed to have
sufficient strength of mind to acquire
what really deserves the name of virtue
but it would seem that if they if they
have human nature there's only one way
for them to acquire happiness and that's
through virtue now what are they told
instead that they should be in a state
of dependency she says if women if it
were allowed that women are destined by
Providence to acquire human virtues and
by the exercise of their understandings
that stability a character which is the
firmest ground on the rest our future
hopes upon they must be permitted to
turn to the fountain of light and not
forced to shape their course by the
twinkling of a mere satellites if you
can't decide for yourself I want to
actually do the right thing not because
somebody is telling you or forcing you
or coercing you forcing your hand but
because you want to do that you want to
make something of yourself you can't
really acquire virtue is what
Wollstonecraft is saying so she's got
this metaphor of you know we should we
should be permitted to turn to the
fountain of light and not forced to
shape our course by the twinkling of a
mere satellite
what would the mere satellite be in that
case a man a man who's you know the
stand infer for what counts as virtue
yeah and she goes on at another point
and she talks about Rousseau Rousseau
has this this idea that women should
always be dependent upon men and she
says to reason in Russo's ground if man
did attain a degree of perfection of
mind when his body arrived at maturity
it might be proper in order to make a
man on his wife one that she should rely
entirely on his understanding and the
graceful Ivy clasping the oak that
supported it would form a hole in which
strength and beauty would be equally
conspicuous so you know the idea the ivy
by the way is kind of a parasitic plant
the ID grows up on the okay ie can't
grow on its own it needs the structure
that the oak provides the oak is the man
the ivy is the woman and
Wollstonecraft's says that's nonsense
that's not gonna work why well a hell of
a lot of men are Oaks a lot of them are
Ivy's themselves they're incapable of
displaying genuine virtue because they
haven't developed it themselves they're
in you know insufficient to the task if
you want to say that women should be
kept in a state of dependency so that
their moral development would be you
know in some way guided by their their
superiors then that has to be a superior
so unless you've got a whole bunch of
other men in mind than the ones that we
typically encounter Wollstonecraft is
saying this is not going to work you're
actually going to be making women worse
off then if they relied under their own
understanding these things make their
own stupid mistakes instead of following
along with the stupid mistakes or their
husbands or brothers or or fathers
there's another problem though that this
leaves you in immaturity if you don't
develop things on your own because you
yourself identify with it at some point
not in childhood but in adulthood you
remain in the state of immaturity that's
not compatible with genuine virtue so
you know for example so long as I'll
give you an example actually from my own
past I remember when I was in the Army
and I did training I have a fear of
falling I have a fear of heights and I
was able to rappel on three occasions
you know rappelling is readable off and
you got a rope but you slide down and
you know it's kind of cool and something
that you might have to do in real
battlefield situations depending on
what's going in ax and I was able to do
it when I had a drill sergeant telling
me if you don't get off of here I'm
gonna throw you off I was able to deal
with the fear and then I remember
getting out of the army and hanging out
the friend of mine who didn't have a
fear of heights and he was like hey
let's go rappel off that railroad bridge
right there which was only about like 30
feet up compared to like doing 120 feet
before that in the army and I found
myself unable to actually do it
for half an hour I sat there with the
Rope you know you hold the Rope behind
your back and you've got the whole
harness on and I would push off and
swing and my hand would clench up and I
couldn't let go and I tried
visualization I tried you know breathing
I tried thinking my way through it my
friend was very nice he didn't like you
know make fun of me or anything then
again perhaps if he'd been fun of me
like you know or said something like the
drill sergeant maybe I would have been
able to do it I wasn't able to do the
task on my own if you develop the things
that you develop only in a state of
dependency then when what you're
dependent on is gone you will not be
able to perform or if you are it'll be
blind luck so if women are supposed to
acquire virtues they need to be able to
acquire virtues out of the context of
dependency how are we doing how are we
going to develop virtues we're going to
develop them through what Wollstonecraft
calls education and she understands this
to mean something quite broad it's more
than just you know formal education it's
all the things that influence the
development of our minds and our
character and we can develop virtues or
develop license or not develop either
through the influence of education an
education can be good or bad so we have
to pay close attention to that and if
women are deprived of any sort of
systemic education that means that
they're probably going to be deprived of
the virtues as well Wilson crafts at
many points stresses that virtue can't
be something that's separated out into
women leaver chiu and males virtue that
doesn't work in her view she calls that
sexual virtue and she says I'm combating
that whole idea
why because if it's going to be virtue
if it's going to be human excellence if
it's going to be what actually brings us
to happiness and what perfects our human
nature men and women have the same
fundamental human nature they have
different genders but they don't have a
different human nature women are not a
different species from men there are
different sex or gender from men but
they're not a different species and so
the perfectioning of women's nature is
the same as the perfectioning of man's
nature there's one standard of virtues
for both men and women she says I see
not the shadow of a reason to conclude
that their virtues should differ in
respect of their nature in fact how can
they if virtue has only one internal
standard if we want to say that virtue
actually means anything and along with
it if we want to say that moral
distinctions like good and bad right
actually means something substantive we
have to have standards that go across
the board probably standards by the way
that most of us are not going to measure
up to all that well if we you know look
at what Wollstonecraft's is advising now
she's willing to say that it could be
the case that men are able to develop
virtues to a greater degree but they're
not virtues of a different kind and
she's putting that in there not because
she actually believes in it but just to
address the possibility she clearly
doesn't believe that men are the ones
who are able to be able to develop
courage to the greatest extent or
fortitude or perseverance to the
greatest extent or injustice or any of
those sorts of things but she is willing
to say that virtues can vary in degree
and we in fact do see that virtues do
vary in degree not everybody is just or
not everybody is this temperent as
everybody else
she also says something else that's very
interesting and she talks about the
possibility of sacrificing virtue for
things what would it be sacrificed for
what are the other possibilities at one
point she talks about sacrificing virtue
to present convenience she says there
could only be one rule of right if
morality has an eternal foundation
whoever sacrifices virtue to present
convenience or whose Duty it is to act
in such a manner lives only for the
passing day and cannot be an accountable
creature so if we're forced to
subordinate the virtues and our
development of them which is what's
really key to us as human beings to
present convenience to staying out of
trouble to you know getting what we want
out of people we're not going to develop
as human beings and that holds just as
much for men as it does for women in the
case of women what is the present
convenience that state of dependency
being treated as objects of attraction
and being given a limited amount of
power but also of being ruled over by by
men for the sake of say security